Speaker 1: Why don't we speak next? You
know, it's always fraught to know where
we go next when it comes to phone calls.
But I believe we're going to go to Ali from
Scotland. Ali, welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: Hi. Thanks for having me,
David. Pleasure. And it's great to be on.
And I actually had a couple of questions,
but I'll keep it to one, just in the interest
of time and some of the growing debates around,
you know, transgender youth, transgender and, you
know, adolescence is all over social media right
now and even in mainstream American discourse.
And I wonder, where do you think it's going? And,
you know, at the very top level, honestly, every
Trump rally, he says infamous line and then no one
should be allowed to teach transgender children
much. And it's like, what does that even mean?
I know exactly like from a grammatical point of
view. And then, yeah, it just doesn't make any
sense, like most of the stuff he says. But where
do you think is going? You know, here's my hope.
Speaker 1: Okay, I'm going to give you here's my
hope of where the anti-trans stuff among the right
is going. My hope is that this is a temporary
stop on the discrimination and marginalization
train. There was a time when the right was
obsessed with gay men. They never really were.
That worked up about lesbians, you might remember.
But like when I started doing the show, they were
obsessed with gay men, and now they've mostly
moved on from gay men. Now trans is the issue,
and specifically it's what they call, quote, men
in women's sports is a heavy part of it. Also,
the things they claim are being done with
regularity when it comes to children which are
not actually being done right now. That's their
focus. And it's really tough for the people that
are being targeted and marginalized by that.
My hope is that eventually they will tire of
the subject and move on to something else.
The problem is who's the next target, Right?
I feel bad for whoever the next target is going
to be, but it's just it's been a shift. They've
gone from obsession with going after gay men.
Now it's the trans stuff. There will be a next
thing. I don't know what it will be and when, but
I hope they move on soon. Although I also want to
protect whoever the next targets are going to be.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I think that's absolutely right.
I mean, I wonder if there's a religious and, you
know, component to this in terms of, you know,
protect the children, save the children, the
left, as they say, the left are attacking
our children. They want to sexualize children,
which as we know, you know, it's not happening,
you know, and they can take a couple of people
and Tick-Tock or rape a couple of, you know,
extreme people in a couple of schools and
the whole of America. And they say this is
what the left is doing. That's what they're
doing. But, you know, it's part of the money.
Speaker 1: I want to add one item to this all. A
part of it is that a lot of the anti-trans stuff
when it comes to kids ties in to their conspiracy
theories about pedophile Democrats and child sex
trafficking and that type of thing. So it's
sort of each has signal boosted the other in a
really convenient way for these right wingers.
Speaker 3: Absolutely. No, that's absolutely
right. I just I wonder where that aspect
is going. You know, it's obviously not the
biggest issue. Yeah, it's not the biggest issue
for me personally either. Right. But, you know,
it's just something I'm interested in.
Speaker 1: Hey, Ali, I have a question for
you. The other day someone told me that when they
were in Scotland, they ate something called Neeps
and tatties. Do you have any idea what that is?
Speaker 3: Yeah. Some of that is a Scottish thing,
which I don't even like. I mean, any such persons.
Last thing. They don't want to kill me for that.
But it's basically potatoes and haggis mixed
into one which sounds, you know, tastes just
as appealing as it sounds. It's really not.
Speaker 1: Great. When you say is it like
you mash up the potatoes and mix in the
haggis, I don't even get what you do.
Speaker 3: I'm in twenties. I've not had it in
such a long time. Oh, it's mainly, you know,
more of an old fashioned thing. Got it. But yeah,
I mean, some people can literally get their fork
and mash it into this one substance and say that
they enjoy it. So y I would recommend that, David.
Speaker 1: All right. Well, listen, if I go to
Scotland, I will look for other forms of cuisine.
Speaker 3: Definitely.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank
you for the call. I appreciate it.
Speaker 3: Thank you very much.
Speaker 1: There goes Ollie from
Scotland. A very, very powerful message.